greetings from podcast Ville it's
Tuesday the 13th of August the podcast
is brought to you by for hems dot-com
listen to me for hems is a one-stop shop
for hair loss skin care and sexual
wellness for men summertime is here
while you may be breaking out the
baseball cap for a day at the beach of
the ballpark if you're wearing it to
hide that thinning hair a little bald
spot those days are over with
don't sweat hair loss this summer do
something now while you can go to 4 hems
dot-com listen for hems provides well
known generic equivalents to name-brand
prescriptions to help you keep your hair
no snake oil pills no gas station
counter supplements prescription
solutions backed by science now the
church family can get a trial month
before hims I saw them on TV last night
this is a real deal company understand
me for five dollars for a trial offer
today while supplies last go to a
website to full details and safety
information listen this will cost you
hundreds if you went to a doctor or a
pharmacy but uncle joey's make it easier
for you by just going for forums comm
slash Joey that's for hims fo r hims
dot-com slash Joey that's it it's nice
and easy for hims dot-com / Joey the
church is also brought to you by the
best [ __ ] CBD oil out there
CBD lion com they make CBD products from
start to finish
CBD lion has you covered go to CBD
line.com right now and check out the
third party lab results some explaining
something I feel the [ __ ] difference
you understand me I feel it in me the
lotion I rub it on my knees when I come
out of the shower I feel the [ __ ]
difference
go to CBD line calm right now press in
church at checkout and they're gonna
take care leave you 20% off
okay try the tincture you try the five
hundred or thousand milligram thing sure
you put that under your [ __ ] tongue
before you go to bed you wake up with a
hard-on that feels like a bottle rocket
you understand me
go to CBD line calm right now Lee kick
this [ __ ] mule baby boy
are you nuts are you [ __ ] nuts
welcome to the Church of what's happened
now uncle Joey here it's a solo podcast
the way you like it today it'll be a
[ __ ] quick one in out no [ __ ]
drama just letting you know what's on
the mind I had a great time in DC at the
Lincoln Theater in Atlantic City at the
I want to thank everybody who came out
to Lincoln Peter Friday night and to the
Beauregard in Atlantic City as you saw
we were back biches the set was good the
Energy's good one [ __ ] fire the comedy
so the plan is working that's the most
important thing I had a plan when I got
off that plane after I shot the Netflix
special and it's working just go to the
store keep becoming a [ __ ] Savage
keep that momentum up I'm not going
anywhere else to weaken me nothing just
straight-up [ __ ] comedy store
following Sebastian run white D'Elia
rogue in all those [ __ ] animals and
guess what if you keep [ __ ] sure you
know you sharpen metal with
[ __ ] metal but anyway now that
we got that over with I had a great
weekend I'm happy you guys came out
we're getting ready for a new [ __ ]
week I want to talk to you about a few
things last episode we spoke a little
bit about respect you know respectful
others respect for yourself and all that
[ __ ] but there's a part of this that
that dirt Saturday night in Atlantic
City when I got offstage bunch of my
friends are there who I hadn't seen from
machardie the Ralph's of fuso to little
McNeal I mean I saw a lot of [ __ ]
cats you know and thank you very much
for always supporting me North Bergen
with all my heart Thank You Union City
West New York Hudson County's always got
my [ __ ] back since day one but
when I was talking to one of the guys he
said to me no it's so funny that you
came out here and that you hang in there
you're talking it's [ __ ] dynamite and
I'm like why would it be
you know why wouldn't I come on talk to
you guys you know you guys were the ones
that kept me together like I've told you
a thousand times you know God took my
family but he showed me to get the
friendship well he showed it to me
through these guys you know and whatever
they knew they knew me at my lowest
[ __ ] point they knew me when I was
robbing and stealing and [ __ ]
cheating and [ __ ] snorting and you
know I would sell my soul and I did I
ended up [ __ ] doing time for but they
knew me at my lowest point you guys let
me in between and you guys have checked
me and kept me [ __ ] honest the last
seven eight years we're doing a podcast
cuz I gotta walk the walk you know I
just can't [ __ ] talk to talk so it's
so weird because at first I didn't think
about it I go why would it be weird it
is how're you got the movies and I know
listen man this is what keeps me honest
is that I keep in touch with those guys
any time I've gone off the reservation
is because I wasn't keeping them - I
only went off the reservation one time
in this town and that's after I shot the
longest shard and it was set induced
like it was the people on the set
telling me what was gonna happen once
this movie came out so it set
expectations for me and I started acting
a little bit [ __ ] weird but going
back to Jersey and walking those streets
reminded me you know sometimes you
listen to the podcast I don't know how
to use complain horrible Joey you talk
about the past and the stories when I
wake up in the morning when I'm peeing
and I'm [ __ ] cheering myself on for
the day as I'm walking there's a bit of
that walk that I think about you know
being in prison or I think about
sleeping in that rocket ship or I think
about [ __ ] sleeping in a bus you know
headed to a gig and Buffalo or something
like that I think about my lowest points
so I'm kept in check
ego is something that I've always
[ __ ] hated I've always hated people
with egos and I've always watched them
and I've seen their destruction little
by little biggest ego wolf
[ __ ] you up whether you're a [ __ ]
plumber a car salesman a comic a
musician I mean how many great bands
have been broken up by egos
I'll tell you three of them the Eagles
was an ego game not as much as the
police and Pink Floyd I love Roger
Waters I'm not saying nothing bad about
Roger Waters but his [ __ ] ego read
his interviews you know listen to his
you know his ego like with like the
creation of the wall he was saying you
know what I don't mind doing shows I
just don't like the [ __ ] fans if I
can build a wall between me and the fans
who would say something like that who
would say something like that the fans
keep your [ __ ] lights on but his ego
was so strong it clashed when guilmon is
done another great man that's done
because the ego the police [ __ ] that
singer has the biggest [ __ ] ego I
just watched him two years ago one night
on one of those late-night shows and he
whipped out a [ __ ] harmonica he said
I'm doing a album and a tour on
harmonica you know why because he was
sitting around drinking wine with a
bunch of his jerk-off friends and
instead of somebody saying do me a favor
Monica way they [ __ ] told them that
it was great and what a great idea so
now for [ __ ] my summer
this [ __ ] went out and played the
[ __ ] harmonica on tour like but is if
you watch his interviews the whole thing
his ego is [ __ ] huge how do you and
maybe just learning how to but how do
you balance because to be an entertainer
you have to have some ego don't you like
it's it seems like you have a little bit
of where the ego comes from okay okay
like I said earlier for a guy like me I
remind myself every day who loved [ __ ]
I was and that keeps me in check when I
shot the longest shard I was a little
[ __ ] up but it's not like I was
throwing water at people
and people affect me a water I just it
was an ego of expectations like I had
something coming to me there's different
types of ego there's you know some
people call white privilege that's a
type of ego you know there's different
[ __ ] egos and you see them in people
you know I'll get nothing racist a great
person once told me that never give a
Spanish person or a black person a
manager's job at Burger King and I
thought it was like a joke and I thought
about it because they egos go out of
[ __ ] control they can't control their
ego you know your ego will make you buy
a [ __ ] house like Michael Jackson
your ego you know it's not that Michael
Jackson went on an interview and said he
was the greatest of all time people like
Kanye West do that and it affects people
people get pissed off you know all that
type of [ __ ] you never heard Biggie
Smalls saying or you know but for some
people they don't have to say it's the
way they walk it's the way they talked I
cannot tell you you know between bands
like music bands you know no this is
just Ritchie Blackmore I had a bad ego
with deep purple and then he carried
that bad ego into [ __ ] rainbow would
do and [ __ ] all the bands he had with
singers he had an amazing [ __ ] you
know an ego you know I'm not staying in
the same hotel as the other guys that
[ __ ] is [ __ ] ego now ego is very
helpful and if you back it there's
nothing wrong with it and you know what
you will back it for a long time but
after that it becomes something else you
know and I don't know what year the
football playoffs Hollywood Henderson
was gonna play guy said he was playing
for the Dallas Cowboys and then we got
playing the Denver Broncos and the
Denver Broncos was known for their
defense and before the game [ __ ] you
know the Denver Broncos were like either
sponsor of the stadium was sponsored by
Orange
or some [ __ ] that's that they called the
defense and they showed how he was
hugging us in an interview drinking an
arm his crush and when he finished it he
squished a can okay that was and that
Sunday and the Super Bowl he intercepted
a ball and he scored a touchdown his ego
he told you he was gonna [ __ ] be a bad
[ __ ] and he was a bad
[ __ ] his ego came through I have
nothing wrong with that but what
happened to him later on his ego mixed
with the cocaine got him thrown out of
the [ __ ] NFL so somewhere along the
line that ego is gonna [ __ ] you ego is
good for some things listen before I go
on stage I'm thinking I'm gonna bomb and
then whether there's one minute as
they're calling my name when I'm falling
apart inside what do you think drives me
to that [ __ ] stage you know what [ __ ]
you you [ __ ] [ __ ]
go up there you've done this a thousand
times stop being a little [ __ ] [ __ ]
stop being a little [ __ ] get on that
stage and kill these [ __ ] that
is ego but it's ego because I put 28
years into it so the ego is backed it's
like [ __ ] for hims it's backed by
saying it's the same [ __ ] deal with
that ego as an artist the enemy [ __ ]
comedians I've seen lose their mind
because of ego and you see it start to
creep up and hopefully they do a film
something outside their John Rowe that
is ego driven and you have you ever seen
when a comic has negative press in the
news about a show or like a movie
performance that checks their ego that
checks your ego when I'm not talking bad
about it at all not saying nothing
negative here
well I'm sure that Tiffany Haddish
didn't feel good after what happened New
Year's Eve in Miami I'm sure I know
Tiffany Haddish on a personal level I'm
sure but in the back of mind how when
you have a busy movie
and you don't have time to go to the
store what to go out at night and when
you do you're [ __ ] too tired because
you've been on six days they're shooting
14-hour days she took the gig because
she said I've done this a thousand times
went down there you guys were expecting
John Mulaney
and she showed up talking and right away
Miami started booing up whatever I
wasn't there all I'm telling you is what
I saw that's an ego driven move but
that's an ego driven moved by somebody
not saying [ __ ] these [ __ ] I know
Tiffany Haddish on a personal level it
was just that Tiffany Haddish didn't
have time to work out I was here I see
Tiffany Haddish going out constantly
lately she hasn't been out she's
probably shooting [ __ ] three movies
but at the same time ego and patting
yourself on the back there's nothing
wrong with it there's a level of comics
right that there's a level of cop that I
saw this I saw this a lot I had a dear
dear dear dear friend here for years I
love them with all my heart great comic
[ __ ] superb writer he wasn't overly
exciting on stage but he was a
phenomenal writer he knew how to write I
mean the guy sold scripts the guy sold
the TV show he was a phenomenal writer
there's no reason why that guy shouldn't
be here today but do you talk to you
want me to tell you how his ego was fan
let me tear his ego got flamed he would
open up for two people in particular and
there were huge acts and bother his deal
was that he would write for them help
them write their act if he could feature
for them and they paid him a little
actually cut himself a nice little deal
and he would watch the headliner and
write jokes for the headline in answer
tags and lines and different things to
help the headliner out but after the
show he would be standing there you know
the headliner would be selling t-shirts
and he'd be standing there like a mortal
Vaughn which I did for years and when I
opened to Joe Rogan
and you see people go up to Rogan shake
his hand tell him how much they loved
him he was great and then they'll walk
over to me and they will go I met you
did a great job then they would come
over and whisper in my ear and now as a
young comic you could take that two ways
you could understand what just happened
this is a guy that was a fan of Rogen's
and he wanted to talk to Rogan so he
blew smoke up his ass and now to either
make me feel right make me feel you know
okay about myself or whatever he comes
over and blow some smoke in my ass now I
could have gone home that and I called
my wife and said hey you're not gonna
believe this I [ __ ] him was up on
stage or Rogan tonight 20 people [ __ ]
told me well let's say three people came
up to me and said that I'll exaggerate
and said forty people came up to me and
told me I was better than rogue and all
five [ __ ] shows [ __ ] this I'm not
opening for him no more I'm gonna go do
my own [ __ ] thing do you understand I
didn't do that because I knew they were
blowing smoke up his ass I watched it
you know they're the same reason why I
did not like the Carlos Mencia feud with
Rogen I saw how club owners were acting
when Rogen came to town they talked bad
about Carlos and Carlos came to town
they talked of bad about Rogen it's a
business what the [ __ ] do you expect
when you get to that town you're the
best [ __ ] thing on sliced bread
because you're making that club all the
money but once you leave he's gonna play
that same [ __ ] game with the comic
that's coming in and I get listen you
know this going in so don't ever feel
bad whatever you do whether you're
playing professional sports whether
you're an artist whether you're a
[ __ ] comic whether you're an actor
don't ever feel bad when you realize
that you're just a [ __ ] meat
with ice something that I've noticed
with you and tell me if I'm wrong is you
definitely take stand-up seriously but
to me I think the difference between you
and some people is you you treat it like
it's a job still
and some people are go home an artist I
gotta I deserve this or like to you it's
still like this is just right do for a
living and and it's a little bit more
black and white it seems like so you
don't leave the room for you get a
little till the ego come in because it's
just it's just a job well when you
realize that you listen when you go to
the comedy store and you look at the
whole picture of the you look at the
wall so you know and you see the comics
that have been there before you you're
gonna find three or four comics that you
either resemble body-wise shape-wise is
the way your material is whatever and
then you realize that you're just
replacing a void okay you're just
replacing a void I'm not ashamed to say
this I'm not ashamed to say this okay
one of the funniest guys I have a saw on
stage was Patrice O'Neal serious
grown-up gangster good guy on an off
stage would make you laugh offstage like
he did on stage was totally free this
especially did the elephant in the room
was something like that white elephant I
guess it's one of the best [ __ ]
specials I've ever seen in my life okay
let's be honest and God rest his soul
and God rest Rafi so most of the people
that are coming to see me today
are coming to see me because there's no
Patrice and there's no Ralphie that's
what you think we are the people were
all in that same category you know they
still have to fill the void I fill that
void right now in two years it'll be
somebody else filling the void but I
know this going in when I got to the
store I would look at noe Gonzales and
see angel Salazar when I'd see Ralphie
may you ever go to the back of the car
there's a picture of a big fat guy
getting out of a car he weighs about 500
pounds I have to look funny with his
name as I pointed out to you going
tonight to the kitchen I look at the
back there's a guy with a cowboy hat
getting out of a car he's 500 pounds
Ralphy replaced him you know when when
John and that was on the downslope who
was hot Ralphy
so everything we're just replacing avoid
once you know all these things going in
why do you think I talked about knowing
things going in knowing what your value
is going in knowing who the [ __ ] you are
when you go in knowing where you stand
keep your [ __ ] mouth shut all these
things are part of it knowing who the
[ __ ] you are knowing what you stand for
you know listen I heard an expression
when I was 13 years old I still use it
today and I use on myself we all put our
pants on one leg at a time you know
that's why to me well I saw Richard Gere
as a kid I didn't go up to him and get
an autograph forget a [ __ ] picture
that's why all those things because at
the end of the [ __ ] day whether it's
Roberto Clemente its Hollywood Henderson
its Lee Iacocca its Ross Perot all the
guys I look up there at the end of it
they all put their pants on I gotta talk
what the [ __ ] are you doing jumping up
and down for um I'm gonna see this movie
and then I'm camping out 24 hours before
are you [ __ ] without it you see them
camping out for you you [ __ ] jerk-off
the [ __ ] is wrong with you we all put
our pants on one leg at a time even you
were going to a job the boy he's the
boss
you can't say this around you know one
one day you look I'm gonna go [ __ ] him
[ __ ] this douchebag he puts his pants on
one leg at a time just like I do once
you get all these basic [ __ ]
philosophies in your head the ego cannot
take over your ego and no part will take
over because respect is part of it you
know when do you start disrespecting
when you think you're better there when
you think they're better they are yet
listen I disrespect the thousand [ __ ]
people I'm talking to him last week I
had to yell at Kate about something but
the result was she sold out all four
shows in DC oh wow
you know that was the result me getting
on her and going tweet those [ __ ]
dates out instead of bikini pictures you
know I feel bad about it but I bet she
felt [ __ ] really good right now you
know these are my friends I gotta look
out for them
you know sometimes as friends we don't
look out for other friends he's got a
call enjoy like last week you called me
with a little bit of a [ __ ] dilemma
about standup that some guy was calling
you asking you creepy questions what'd I
tell you call them back and come to go
[ __ ] himself
if he wants the [ __ ] hiya this is the
deal if not you know I'm making the
ten-hour Drive anyway you ain't got time
you ain't got [ __ ] time right
why because you just don't have the time
there's a thousand open mics down here
you're not looking to make money right
now you that not at all if you're
looking to make money quit right now
because there's no money in your future
you're gonna pick up a 20 here or 40
here I'll throw you something when you
open for me but besides that ain't no
money in this game so all these things
as long as you know going in you know
when you walk into that job yeah well
you walk into a job like let's say
you're a roofer or some you walk in here
like hey look who it is
you know they blow smoke up your ass and
they tell you how great they feel not on
the way out they say y'all don't forget
you gotta work Saturday you know I gotta
go to a wedding though my family but you
have to work on [ __ ] Saturday
you know they will smoke up your ass to
get you to work on Saturday you know
better than nobody else will know better
than nobody else it's 300 [ __ ] comics
out there that are better than me
seriously
fundamentally stand up I mean punch line
set up [ __ ] the structure there's a
thousand comics better than me there's a
thousand coming and I know that I know
that go on it I try to be myself more on
stage what helps me a lot more but all
these little things that will prevent
you from getting ego one time
and we never talked about on the podcast
well I'll tell you right now I think in
the 22 year friendship I had with
Ralphie
I had one misunderstanding with we
didn't talk for about three months he
was supposed to pick me up he called me
like 10 [ __ ] times made me stop when
I was doing that day I was doing
something and he called he called he
called he called and he told me was
picking me up at a certain time and then
I didn't hear from him for six hours and
when he called me I didn't say nothing
on the phone but when I got my car got
rest his soul I looked at him and I
straight up looked at him and I go hey
do you think your time is more valuable
than mine and he looked me in the face
and he said yes to me and I don't
remember what I said to him but it
wasn't to [ __ ] plus I said it to him
in a friendly way and a friendly way I
said this to him you know whatever about
time and we did what we had to do but
when we left I knew that he didn't like
it
but I didn't really give a [ __ ] because
I was his brother and it was time that
somebody told him nobody had the balls
to tell him what I told him in that car
that day he didn't call for about two or
three months he bumped into my friend
George in Jersey George told him who I
was and it was forgotten about and
Ralphie was never landing it because he
came to understand that Nate this guy's
got a point here he's right I don't give
a [ __ ] if you're late just pick up the
goddamn phone
and go listen at 3:30 call me and go hey
I'm stuck around the corner I'll be that
3:30 for that that I could take that hey
I won't be there for an hour I'll be
there for two hours anyway that's not
the point the point is that sometimes
you know and that's what happened the
people like Roger Waters that's what
happens to people like sting nobody in
that camp has the balls to come up to
you and tell you that you're slipping
that's the biggest issue you have out
here
that everybody's walking on [ __ ]
eggshells and they'll a I've seen
[ __ ] comics bro
I'll get a couple thing with that
success could be in that path and they
[ __ ] up at the end with ego just
destroy it would ego and then guess what
happens they disappear you never hear
from them again
they they end up in some [ __ ] City or
doing local comedy ego is a [ __ ] you
gotta check it this is why it was really
shocking when the guy told me that they
are there at the show I never listen
every damn I'm who the [ __ ] I am or
where I came from and I rob Michaels
jewelers and I think about sleeping on
that metal [ __ ] bed and diagnostic
for two [ __ ] weeks and that's what
keeps me how many people ask me why
don't you travel with a road manager why
don't you have security why don't you
have you know like why don't you have a
publicist why don't you have people
around you when you travel like [ __ ]
what they call that entourage yeah are
you [ __ ] [ __ ] are you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
I need an entourage I need my stylist to
travel with me I need my trainer to
travel with me is that what you [ __ ]
think you know the other day me and Matt
full trunk out on the train the only
people came up to me on the train is so
what are you doing on [ __ ] train what
I can't take a train right I can't take
a damp rag I blew you I need to be in a
[ __ ] helicopter I'm a celebrity I'm
just an r-rated [ __ ] comic who thirty
years ago this week got sense the
[ __ ] prison
that's the cooler [ __ ] I am sure this is
a job this is a job I put 28 years into
and right now I'm reaping the rewards
from I worked for every minute that I do
on [ __ ] stage I worked hard towards
it what would ruin this right now drugs
and ego a both of them together ego
would ruin this right now Lee Lee has a
way of saying things sometimes like one
of the biggest things I ever heard from
Lee
was that the only gannets haven't worked
out with me as you and you're an
ex-convict they went to prison for
kidnapping Lee does all this business
with all these high-level people and
they stop calling him they fall upon it
the [ __ ] seems this is a job for me
this is a job and when it became a job
for me is when I became successful when
I started becoming successful you know
for the first six or seven years of
comedy this was not a job for me I was
just learning my ropes around the same
way and you start you have you guys
started out as labourers picking garbage
up and fetching coffee and [ __ ] we
don't have to fetch coffee or pick
garbage up but like I was telling Lee
getting booed is the same [ __ ]
feeling you know after a king can you
imagine being somewhere for two years
and still getting coffee the lunch order
you start feeling bad about yourself but
what keeps you [ __ ] going is that
you're working you're working towards a
goal you go you know what who gives a
[ __ ] if he called me a fat [ __ ] I'm
working every day I'm [ __ ] working
and I'm getting better at this and some
damn to be able to break away from him
and do this on my own and that's when
I'll get my last laugh and my last
result that's the whole bottom line for
this thing but to go back to ego man I
don't believe in it I don't and in this
town I see it starting in comedy you
know these guys go to Montreal they get
a [ __ ] deal and I'm supposed to
[ __ ] come up to you and kiss your
ring meanwhile I'm Battle of the story
[ __ ] night six nights a week
following fall morning you know what
suck my dick you know so again they were
trying to make me feel bad by not
inviting me to Montreal fifteen twenty
years ago but at the same time who
needed Montreal
I was following [ __ ] Paul Mooney and
every night I was bombing oh yeah I was
bombing and my ego is getting [ __ ]
kicked in the stomach oh but I kept
showing up every day and that's that's
part of he
go you know I don't need to go down
there I don't need to do this anymore
I'm this good no Lee what do I tell you
you gotta do the same steps every day
every day every [ __ ] day and I do
miss boring is this today already I
[ __ ] wrote for an hour
I went lift it now with the cryotherapy
I sent emails I got my spots at the
store why because I have a list I got it
all written down I have a plan for the
[ __ ] day so all these things guess
when I'll start to fail when I say oh
you know what I don't need to write
anymore
I don't need to [ __ ] lift weights
anymore I could skip out on this I could
skip out on this No
what do I tell you it's the same [ __ ]
every [ __ ] day guess what the same
amount of work you put in your fourth
year of being a carpenter guess what
[ __ ] you're gonna put that same amount
of work for even more when you when
you're 20 get years into it and now
you're on your own [ __ ] business what
do you think it's a it's a 20 hour a
week oh yeah this is want to know that
40-hour a week when you play games and
play for keeps
it becomes an 80 hour week but it
doesn't matter because you're doing
something you love and you're doing it
for yourself and everything you do is
geared towards that same [ __ ] goal
you know what guys I'm 56 years old I
got a wife but I got a kid I don't need
the [ __ ] weight watcher it normal I
don't need to really go to the [ __ ]
gym no more but for me to give you guys
a great show I know I need to do all
these things I need to do all these
things this is all part of a job this is
a [ __ ] job and part of that job is
keeping me together because once your
mind goes that's when everything else
[ __ ] goes so if it's going a box or
going you know what man I just finished
two shows this weekend I had great
[ __ ] shows between you and I guys I
was gonna do Sam tripley show tomorrow
night and then take time off this
weekend next week that was my plan to
just stay home and focus on writing this
book and focus on writing this one-man
showing some more material you even
stand up a break
guess what I can't you know why because
I went to Jersey August [ __ ] 10th and
I'm gonna be back in Jersey all Cober
25th or some [ __ ] and that gives me two
months to come up with another [ __ ]
half-hour because half the [ __ ]
people I came in selling me in [ __ ]
August I'm gonna come in the [ __ ]
October so if I had an ego and I didn't
respect you [ __ ] I would go who
gives a [ __ ] what I say I'm gonna show
up there in October and [ __ ] do the
same material but I can't I can't
because I understand that you have to
get a babysitter I understand that
you're excited to see man and they said
what if I have you come to see him in
October and I have the exact forty five
[ __ ] minutes you're gonna say yeah he
was funny but I heard three quarters of
this [ __ ] already so I can't take a
break off that was my plan until I got
to Atlantic City and after people in
Atlantic City with telling me eh
we'll come on we got tickets to come see
you in October or in December in New
York oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
so that week I had planned off the
[ __ ] relax with my family and the end
that bet it there that means suck my
dick in Italian it's nothing for you
I gotta work it out now so I gotta hit
the [ __ ] books so you people if I had
the ego I wouldn't give a [ __ ] let them
[ __ ] spend the $30.00 and if they
don't like it let them go [ __ ]
themselves but they like it I can't do
that to you guys cuz I understand the
work I understand what you're putting
into sacrifice I gotta go to a movie
tonight I'm gonna meet Rick Ramos that's
why I was looking at the head acid
because seven o'clock they're showing
Apocalypse Now at the cinema I'm a domme
oh damn and then you do a [ __ ] live
interview with Laurence Fishburne and Oh
Francis Ford Coppola [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah
so I mean Rick Ramos down there at seven
o'clock I don't know how I'm alive and
listen the first time I saw Apocalypse
Now
I took a [ __ ] hit that double barrel
sunshine acid it was a Friday night
midnight late movie because they
Apocalypse Now was so popular when they
came out
the Hannah had viewings this was early
on you know back when movies were coming
out it was like the movie started 11:30
in the morning and then there was
another viewing at two four seven nine
and then maybe 10:30 is something
whatever the [ __ ] but for all those
movies they started doing midnight
movies so me and my buddies took [ __ ]
double-barreled sunshine and we went up
to the Fairview [ __ ] sit him in the
old days and there was a line maybe you
know I don't know how many [ __ ]
people are going to see because the
Fairview cinema had to [ __ ] movie
theaters and there were two [ __ ]
there were two lines forming to go to
each movie theater but there was a
Carvel up the corner from [ __ ] not
even up the corner in the same strip
mall 50 yards so when I was standing on
line I'm tripping on the ass I'm
starting to trip this [ __ ] like that and
I see an ice cream call somebody boy
life came cold and right before they
went until the movie theater they threw
it on the sidewalk and there was ant
starting to grow around it was not again
it started melting and it was like four
of us they was like me Kurt Dee Lorenzo
Louie cast only though and this kid John
Crowley and John Crowley was missing a
[ __ ] what a wrench nut somewhere and
he was tripping on acid whenever he was
tripping on acid I kept talking about
anything and I know John I'm not waiting
on that [ __ ] line but the only way
we're gonna cut through was if you
[ __ ] throw an obstacle at these guys
i daily eat that ice cream cult and he
walked over his hitter has picked up the
ice-cream cone with the ants on it and
started licking the front of the line I
grabbed him and may believe like I was
controlling them
and I stood right there and they open up
the doors and we walked in first that's
how you do it [ __ ] that's why
you're always gonna have a crazy friend
oh my god meets weird kind of bugs and
[ __ ] like that and that's it didn't end
that well we got in Toulouse
Paul so it didn't end there well we got
in there we were tripping our balls are
so [ __ ] hard that before the movie
started we talked them into going to the
front of the movie theater and talking
to people so he got up Danny as they can
I have your attention please and people
like shut the [ __ ] up get the [ __ ] out
of the way and some guys they let him
talk he's the guy that ate the ice cream
cold out there can you sit through in a
three-hour movie on acid we did oh [ __ ]
because it's such a dark [ __ ] movie
and there's fireworks and I would have
run out of there oh my god and tonight
I'm gonna I'm thinking about eating this
[ __ ] just the opening with the ceiling
fan and the helicopter that would get me
I'm thinking about [ __ ] making a
reservation at Danny Tanner's going down
there after I've eaten and then right
from there to avoid the traffic shoot
over and watch the first two hours of
Apocalypse Now roll like three joints
and then wait that part where they go to
French and they talking to the French
people I hate that old dinner party
sighs let's hope enjoy the two that I go
with cats the end and do the [ __ ] Q&A
with Laurence Fishburne and my man
[ __ ] Francis Ford Coppola who's
better than uncle Joey
no body [ __ ] I gotta do this I
don't eat listen guys I'm a movie buff
I'm surprised you've never seen I don't
know the last time I saw you do a movie
without your life I saw an ad I don't I
don't think my wife wants a girl I'm
saying you do movie night date night
like once a week but that's it yeah well
I'm not gonna see the Hollywood thing
cuz the disrespect Bruce Lee so I've
heard it too many times
you can't disrespect Bruce Lee so I'm
not going to see I'm boycotting [ __ ]
I'm just saying it's cool you're
actually going to see a movie oh yeah no
no highlight more I'm a movie buff this
is what I do this is what I did all my
[ __ ] life I smoke pot and I watched
movies and I studied and I got inspired
and this movie really inside and I want
to talk to Laurence Fishburne
I met him that one time with Ralphie and
he was very very sweet and I wanna go
down and maybe talk to him about coming
on the podcast or something because his
daughter trains around the corner where
my daughter trains
oh yeah yeah yeah I've never seen him
down there but I know she she's told me
and I saw pictures in there so in my
world he's one of the greatest black
actors a long time I mean especially now
I think and I'm a big Denzel fan but
like when you really really do the math
there's nobody better as an
african-american then from [ __ ] you
know what's love got to do with it to
that movie with Christopher Walken to
[ __ ] the ones with Keanu Reeves now
with John wick CSI the movie with Sean
Penn away when he playing opposite Kevin
Bacon I mean the guy is just [ __ ]
sensational that's what inspires the
[ __ ] out of me is going to see a guy
like that and when I spoke to him and
met him that's when I was really
impressed by that there was no ego he
pull he saw me and Ralphie standing on a
corner waiting and going to a weed store
and I had just had a special come on
show time I forget what it was called
with George Perez and Marilyn whatever
pie-yah so calmly slam I had just done
it it was on Showtime and I was praying
that nobody watched it and he pulled
over we were in from the weed store by
the Formosa cafe and he pulled over and
we were just standing and he came out of
the car and walked up to us
[ __ ] Laurence Fishburne just walked
up to us [ __ ] look what he guys don't
stand there and we told him were about
to go onto the weed stored that he want
to wait and smoke with us he said no and
he said no he had saw me on the payaso
slam and he had saw a Ralphie and Last
Comic Standing
I mean he just pulled over on Santa
Monica Boulevard right by the formal
office of cafe right across the street
there's still a weed store there that's
the first place that drew me out because
I told my mama that give me what could
give me what give me what you've got
here to see the devil and the girls like
we don't talk like that here and he came
up to me was like you can't talk like
that hey you gotta leave was it the
Christian no no this is the one this was
in Formosa across the street from the
[ __ ] Formosa cafe right there it's
all different now but I went past the
other day and it's still there it's not
as popular as it used to be I
like it because you had to wait outside
it's weird they would come up there
would be a security guard outside and he
you gave me a wallet your license and he
would have to go in and check and then
come back out so you had to wait on line
like a little bit outside in the street
ahead but that night I was happy I was
waiting outside cuz Laurence Fishburne
came out and started talking to us and
we spoke for about forty five [ __ ]
minutes
we didn't even end up going and buying a
week what we were just we were just you
know in heaven that Laurence Fishburne
was talking to us so we just talked to
him about comedy and acting he referred
me to an acting teacher which me and
Silent Bob Rodrigo Torres yeah we signed
up and Rick Ramos and Rick Rambis all be
together because it was Laurence
Fishburne's buddy
it was where Laurence Fishburne worked
out so we all gave it a shot for about
six months but then we all wanted
different ways my moved up here Rick
Remo sure you know did something else
but I wonder if he remembers you that'd
be crazy cool Lawrence he's gonna
remember I remember that's why because
we had a great conversation you know we
spoke about him being 16 years old and
shooting Apocalypse Now and how he had
to get his [ __ ] his mother to go down
to the Philippines with him because he
was only 16 when he shot it just an
interesting story just an interesting
[ __ ] guy so I figured what the [ __ ]
I'll go down there tonight maybe a half
a sheet of this acid [ __ ] yeah and watch
cuz I loved that whole thing it's got
one of the one of the lines and that
movie is well always that keeps me
[ __ ] going while I'm sitting here on
this [ __ ] couch getting weaker
Charlie is in the bush getting stronger
that is a classic [ __ ] line that's
why I than four years every time I
caught myself on the street corner
talking [ __ ] I would go what the [ __ ] I
gotta go case and join up I gotta go rob
somebody I'm over here while [ __ ] I'm
sitting here wasting my time Charlie's
in the bush getting stronger those words
the [ __ ] just amazing it just grabs
your entire personality that hey I'm in
the bush getting [ __ ] stronger that's
all that matters to me that's the most
and king of this [ __ ] the whole thing
and then really quick I wanted to give a
shout-out to Rodrigo his wife she's had
a baby
congratulations to my man Rodrigo I will
call him right after this I have not
spoken to him in a few weeks and I did
not know about his child
right a lot of people don't know Rodrigo
is Felipe site kick on what's happening
fool the podcast you know and look at
the people that I bring into my life
solely pain does not have an ego you
know after I had the words of Ralphie
his ego disappeared you know Tom Segura
does not have an ego Chris D'Elia does
not have an ego if you talk to Sebastian
there's really no ego involved I mean as
Sebastian don't say much as it is he's
on he's on I think fighter in the kid
today or he's doing the CIO's podcast
today but you know these guys don't have
on the ego you know Ron White are you
kidding me there's no ego that Ron knows
we all know listen when you realize how
lucky you are for being in this position
your ego should disappear your ego
should disappear you know I love doing
movies but one of the things that turned
me off about movies was the ego of a lot
of actors it really [ __ ] his eternal
you you see it they come in late you
know instead of eating what's for lunch
they gotta send out because they don't
like the food you know and it's not an
ego thing they go out of their way to be
different to let you know that they're
better than you are at some level and
I've never liked that [ __ ] mentality
that's the celebrity mentality you know
what it one race how do they sell you oh
do what the celebrities are doing you
know what's up - what's a chick the the
chicken on [ __ ] my 500 pound not my
vote
what was the fat loss show on NBC Julian
I'm like yeah you know train how the
celebrities train
that's what they say on that if they
sorry on why because the celebrities
will do things differently just to make
you feel ordinary well no no we don't do
ordinary weights we too underwater
weights with a guru makes you lift with
[ __ ] shorts on you know there's
always something with those
[ __ ] and at the end of the week
they're not doing nothing they're just
going out of their way to let you think
that they're better than you are don't
ever feel that way because I used to
always like feeling secure about it for
years
I thought they'd secure about people why
he goes I didn't like how it made me
feel and once I figure that I cut those
[ __ ] people up I can tell you 20
comics that have huge [ __ ] egos I
talk to them but I avoid them like the
plague
and I just watch them they're like my
side project how long for the [ __ ]
Leaning Tower of Pisa goes down it's a
leaning tower because your head ain't
right whenever your head ain't right
you're [ __ ] leaning to the side I
know I am whatever my head's not right
it affects everything that I do around
me if you're [ __ ] up somewhere it
affects everything you do around you and
the man who told me that was Joe Rogan
when I was doing blog he's like what you
when you do blow it affects everything
you do around you so all those negative
personality traits like not having
respect is what you have when you get a
[ __ ] ego you know will prompt me for
that respect prop a podcast was
something that had happened a few nights
early at a comedy club that somebody got
up and ran a light the same reason why
you run a light is to prove that you're
better than somebody else I can run the
light I have [ __ ] ego that's why you
run away there's people who run away by
mistake all the time
I know they're running I lied by mistake
but there's people that to prove a point
to you that they're better than they
than you are don't run the light as a
comic that's why I say it's a bad
because that's the vibe it sends out it
doesn't know he ran the light it's just
three [ __ ] word
but you're telling me hey you don't give
a [ __ ] and be that you're better than I
had and who tells you that you're
[ __ ] he go feed you that [ __ ]
so just remember in life no matter how
good or success where you get at
something you're just a [ __ ] meat bag
with eyes there's a guy behind you
waiting to grab your success when you
[ __ ] force yourself down with your
stupid [ __ ] characteristic a [ __ ]
ego do you think it's like let's say
someone's listening to this and they're
like [ __ ] I have too much ego is there
have you seen people switching around
you is there a way like when you run
what knocks out ego what quiets down ego
I don't know getting your ass kicked
life kicks the [ __ ] out of you you know
we were talking about that I did
Caroline's when yeah I did the New York
Comedy Festival and the guy didn't like
me so he told me he was gonna book me in
a certain time when I got there they
told me there was a band going up front
of me you know I'm saying there was a
band going up in front of me when I got
off and I ate a bag of dicks I realized
why the bag of dicks Baba it hurt me you
know I get hurt me whatever but that
didn't bruise my ego like how do you how
do you turn it around how do you go from
having too much ego tonight you get your
ass kicked you get your hand hand level
to you well like let's say you know it's
like that guy that when you walks off
stage and looks at you as a comic and
goes follow this [ __ ] you could turn
around and smack that [ __ ] or you go up
there and I'll do the [ __ ] and
then not saying a word to him like
that'll bother him more than you say
something ego goes away when you get
your ass kicked if you're a normal
person
the ego goes in check you know is your
way to get your act like like cuz
getting your ass kicked sometimes
happens when you're not expecting it or
if someone's trying to change well then
you're asked it could be a girl cheating
on you two eating a bag of dicks on
stage two getting fired from you
you know you get egotistical at your job
I made that decision cuz I thought it
was the right one well you lost $60,000
for the company so you got right there's
no mistakes and [ __ ] and that that
corporate environment that corporate
world so ego poor shoe to make a mistake
that mistake levels you and the next
thing you know who we are
you've got nowhere to go you know I was
watching something the other day on an
interview on MMA junkie who I really
read all their interviews and it had to
do with kabhi fight McGregor got my Greg
saying he wants him or something and he
told him he goes amen
not for nothing you lost the last two or
three fights why you [ __ ] you have no
room to speak you know he wasn't being
and I looked at that and I'm like he's
not being a bad person one he saying the
truth
and two he's like I'm not gonna fight
you you could fight the winner a Dustin
and me you know you could that you lost
your last two fights I beat you I choked
you out decisively you know that must
have controlled if you watch the
McGregor fights when he lost he sound
the mat for a minute and you think about
especially the khabib one he sat on the
mat for a few minutes and thought about
where he went wrong the training and a
lot putting down McGregor or nothing
like this I'm just saying that sometimes
that ego right now.i McGregor has been
for how long close to a year plant you
know what how it's like you like getting
on stage for you it's like you doing
three big [ __ ] Academy Award winner
movies but you don't get on stage for a
year Erick's Roach is gonna pass you by
Kristi Bellis is gonna pass you by the
chick with the ass that travels all the
time is going to pass you by these
people are gonna pass you by and and now
you know ego makes you do all those bad
decisions ego makes you say all those
things and at the end what did you make
what did you get what did you gain do
you have Steve still going they're still
doing their fights and
they're adjusting without Connor and
they're waiting for him to come back and
he's gonna be a year 16 months behind
not getting in the [ __ ] ring
you know last two weeks ago three weeks
ago there was a big article and people
were furious I mean I read thousand
different reviews on Eddie Murphy you
know Netflix thinks he's worth seventy
million dollars I love any Murphy I
wouldn't be sitting in this chair if it
wasn't funny Murphy delirious is a great
[ __ ] special
Roy is a great [ __ ] special but people
were wondering how much now Eddie Murphy
has not agreed to it yet I love Eddie
because of that now if you watch Eddie
and getting coffee with King yeah with
satellite phone they discuss that listen
to what are you saying that he hates
going onstage without not saying
something this is a guy that has made 20
great movies that has been around since
1983 what's that 93 2003 this is a guy
that's got a 37-year career as a [ __ ]
comic and there's a comedic actor any
other person who would get a 70 million
dollar offer already would have signed
up and [ __ ] the date would have been
set the dates would have been released
but what did he say on that thing with
with with Seinfeld he goes to [ __ ]
get on stage you gotta work out I I
watch part I got nothing to say he said
that Wow I really can't get on stage
without having something to say it made
me respect Eddie Murphy more than I've
ever respected them because any other
household you know what and I've heard
it before
8:00 and sky take the 70 million you
could talk [ __ ] for an hour yeah that's
I mean that that's that's a level of non
ego cuz I mean what what would you do if
they offer you 7 million like that's
like 7 million I'd agree to it but first
off if you offer
me seven million dollars it's August so
it would be 12 I would have to shoot it
in January of 2021
if you offered me 7 million dollars I
would start from scratch
whatever deposit they gave me I would
hire Neal Brennan John Mulaney
Whitney Cummings I would hire anybody it
was a great writer to just I'd pay them
I'd pull a Chris Rock I think Chris Rock
was another thing years ago when there
was no ego he went back to his friends
that's why I love Chris Rock he got a I
think a quarter man in advance he gave
Richard Jeni 50 louis c.k 50 and Nick
DiPaolo 50 and said help me with my
special everybody show up with 15
minutes all those specials you saw all
those years
well that was brilliant he had those
guys he had Jenny the paolo and louis
c.k so if each one of them showed up
with 15 minutes and Chris showed up with
22 minutes of his own material and
webbed off for those two I still
remember seeing Chris come up to the
strong on Monday night and do 30 minutes
with [ __ ] Jenny Lewis CK and Nick
DiPaolo in the audience you know how
strong that is young Lee comics would do
that
zero-zero I want to have a [ __ ]
phenomenal special Lisa Incorporated is
giving me a million dollars to shoot a
special it is gonna be [ __ ] smoking
guess what at the end of the special I'm
probably gonna die of a heart attack
that's how good the special is gonna be
I'm gonna go above and [ __ ] beyond
for this I'm gonna train the right way
I'm not gonna you know when Netflix
called me to do this special they called
an April for me to be ready in June you
know I I'm not making excuses I'm not
making any excuses
I'm the one that accepted it I didn't
think about it you know and it was an
ego thing it was just I wanted to do
something for Netflix I figured how long
would it take me to write a half-hour
and you see what the result is you see
what the [ __ ] result is so I really
take my hands off to
Murphy for not taking the 70 million and
going hey who gives the [ __ ] what they
think I'm 50 something years old
it really doesn't [ __ ] matter anybody
could say that
so yeah it's time to put an action so
it's very hard so that's that's why
those are the comics that don't have an
ego you know one of the guys that I
really miss I speak to him from time to
time and we spoke about him coming out
of the podcast and he's been on the
podcast before I think he's called in
what was the guy that did all the prior
specials and well um what we've
discussed that I really the director the
other director that when they helped him
write Jo Jo dancer this is your life is
calling and stuff you know one thing I
really really like about him one thing I
really enjoyed about him was the story
told me about prior that the prior show
was kind of working and rock or be stuck
or BC and they were doing a lot of blow
and stuff and the suits from MB Rocco
was a young man he had just been out of
college this is his first job in
production and that you know MBC told
Richard Pryor that he was you know or
richard ass NBC the two suits remember
you see you think I'm doing too much
coke and they're like no mr. Pryor have
a great time keep doing what you're
doing and Rocco told him no I think
you're doing too much coke that's
affecting you work and he threw Rocco
out and fired him and three days later
he contact on he goes you know what I
thought about what would happen then you
are honest of being so come back to work
and that was there you know I think that
Richard probably had you know and that's
why I always say when you're a real
[ __ ] and somebody says some to
you and your ears it sounds off-color
you might argue it a little bit and then
you go home and you think about the
words and you give it three or four days
and you figure out that this person that
said something to you that was love
color was just trying to help you he
didn't present it wrong either you know
I wouldn't be here today if it wasn't
for Matt woods you know in 1994-95 yeah
I was getting the reputation as one of
the funny open mic errs and I was making
headway I was doing more time I was also
devoting myself and I was also sticking
my neck out I was doing comedy at a at a
weird time I was doing comedy while I
was angry and depressed and I was broke
and the comedy was the only thing that
was keeping me alive but making myself
you know it's like I know a girl right
now that's going through a breakup and
she called me about two weeks ago and I
said are you going through a breakup
what's the best time to get on stage and
she think well I don't talk what are you
[ __ ] kidding me you brought somebody
dumped [ __ ] you get on stage four times
a night and she called this weekend and
said thank you that was the best advice
anybody gave me because I learned how to
do comedy from a bad place not a good
place anybody could go onstage when you
have a job and the things are right and
your rent is paid keep getting on stage
when your love life isn't going well or
your girlfriend sucking some [ __ ]
Armenian dick and Glendale or you know
you can't pay the rent
that's what comedy is is going through a
hard time and getting up on stage and
fighting through that hard time you know
like I told you guys
February whatever getting off a plane
and finding out Brody's dead and I still
had to go do a [ __ ] comedy show and I
mean you know deep down you're falling
apart but you got to do a comedy show I
thanked myself but in 1995-96 I would
force myself to get on stage 94 even
though I was going through hell anybody
else that said [ __ ] I can't get on
stage I'm going through something well
[ __ ] go through it on stage if you're
going through some
thing go through it on stage who's a
better therapist than a [ __ ] audience
so anyway I appreciate you guys listen
today if you have ego problems if this
has happened to you you'll understand
where I'm coming from and if one of your
friends ever comes up to you and says
that you're getting a little bit too big
for your [ __ ] britches before you
smack them think about where he's coming
from think about your situation think
about how it affects the people around
you and you'll see that you get right
back to [ __ ] square one because ego
doesn't get you anything but a losing
[ __ ] result you know today we live
without the police and pink floyd the
world is deprived the [ __ ] pink floyd
the full band because of one [ __ ]
jerk-off
we can't hear the police because of one
[ __ ] jerk-off you know and I think
that's a goddamn shame but anyway the
Church of what's happened now
this is how we do it here I want to
thank all the people who listen I want
to thank the people came out to AC and
[ __ ] DC it was the ACDC weekend
it was fantastic I had a great time it
was great seeing you guys real quick the
31st of August I'm at the ice house
Memorial Day weekend or Labor Day
weekend in the small room working out
with uncle Joey
San Antonio sold out September 14th but
there's still tickets available for
Dallas February 13th show up with the
black cat know which hat [ __ ] February
no September whatever the [ __ ] it is and
then the last week of September I'm at
the Chicago theater with Bob Lowe Lingus
and the [ __ ] crew so get your tickets
now if you want to come that's a great
data it's it's gotta had a lot of great
memories in there with little esther and
ari and duncan then [ __ ]
Rogen there was a great [ __ ] show
somebody's i had to beat all back there
real quick before we wrap it up i want
to talk to you about CBD lion doctor
music nekton Joey I don't know what to
do people are talking about CBD
says this my cousin says that what do I
do listen picking a reliable CBD company
is like getting [ __ ] in the [ __ ]
ass all right
especially now I mean if you go 150
yards from a Magnolia Boulevard I think
there's three stores close to us that
have CBD signs baa me I go with CBD lion
comm why because then you go to CBD line
calm they'll show you their third-party
test results right there on the website
listen no matter how you want it they
give it to you they may see me be
products from start to finish and you
got a you got your [ __ ] choice they
got you covered at every level whether
you want to vape it whether you want to
cartridges whether you want the shadow
if you're not into smoke and they got
delicious raspberry and orange and
strawberry gummies and they do a [ __ ]
tension like I said start with the 500
1000 milligram tincture
put it under your [ __ ] tongue and let
it go to work their products are [ __ ]
clean Bobby and then I like these fake
[ __ ] and false advertising and
you listen don't buy that [ __ ] you might
as well drink gain Seng from a liquor
store - you dumb [ __ ] go to CBD Lyon
right now CBB lying calm and check out
that third-party tech lab results for
yourself the church family gets 20% off
at checkout go to CBD lion calm right
now and start your CBB regiment today
you won't be [ __ ] sorry
number two the church is also brought to
you by for him stomp or hims is a
one-stop shopping for hair loss skin
care and sexual wellness for men you
having a problem getting that [ __ ]
love stick going for hims could help you
if you having a problem with hair loss
for hims can help you I love this
company because listen don't sweat hair
loss this summer do something why you
still got your hair when you can still
save it like I told you before 66% of
men lose their hair by the age of 35 why
the hell do you turn to with solutions
that do nothing when you could turn to
medicine and science for hems com has
the answer
they have well-known generic equivalents
to name-brand prescriptions that help
you keep your hair like I said no snake
war pills no gas station counter
supplements prescription solutions
backed by science you have to go nowhere
either there's no waiting room
no awkward in-person doctor visits the
guy looks you in the eye you save ours
by going to for hims dot-com it's very
easy answer a few quick questions a
doctor will review it and prescribe you
exactly what you need
stop worrying about sun block on your
boss thinning hair and do something stop
the hair loss today and help promote
hair growth the products also a shipped
directly to your door you know got a
going away you're gonna say no Bonnie
right to your door boom there knock on
the door you do whatever you gotta do it
right so do me a favor
right now the church family gets a trial
month two hymns for five dollars
so we need five dollars five dollars
they give you a trial month of hymns for
five hours right now while supplies last
go to the website for full details and
safety information let me tell you
something
this will cost you hundreds of dollars
if you went to a doctor or a pharmacy
uncle Joey's gonna save you money
Christmas is around the corner go to
four hens comm slash Joey that's four
hymns fo r hims get the pen fo r hims
comm slash Joey that's four hymns comm
slash Joey alright see website for full
details and safety information again I
want to thank for hems again I want to
thank CB d line com but most importantly
I want to thank you guys for all of the
support you've given Lea and I over the
years you come to the shows you [ __ ]
jump up and down but most importantly
you learn you listen and you take
something away from this podcast I'm not
saying we're the best podcast or the
worst podcast but there's always a
message here somewhere for you and if
not we try to make you laugh you know
I'm a filthy [ __ ] they're like
having a good time I love your
[ __ ] I'll see you Wednesday
morning
what Thursday morning tip top but goo
ready to go if not I see at the end of
the month at the ice house
worried 13th in Dallas or September I
don't even know I keep saying February
30 people they know what the [ __ ] I'm
talking about they know I'm not doing I
don't even know what the [ __ ] I'm doing
in February so don't worry about me and
see the next month to go funky mother I
love you [ __ ] I see it Thursday
morning
stay black Lee kick this [ __ ]
meal